well presidential hopeful joe biden is
no stranger to the uk
he has an even more special relationship
with
ireland here rekindling the ancestral
link on a visit to county laoth in 2016.
he's carried this with him throughout
the campaign
with irish members of his extended
family like lorita blewett
traveling to las vegas earlier in the
year to help him
joe biden has been brought up since a
small child with very strong
irish values and i know it's very
important to him i know he's very in
touch with
um you know our struggles here in
ireland
we've recently just painted a big mural
him in the town in balinas so i was able
to send him pictures of the updates of
that and he was
so excited and so proud of it and the
last thing he said to me
in february when i left i'm definitely
going to make it a priority to get back
to ireland hopefully as president
but could that irish link also prove
problematic for boris johnson
this diplomatic bombshell in september
would suggest
it could mr biden declared on twitter
that he would not allow peace in
northern ireland to become a casualty
of brexit meanwhile irish officials told
sky news that if relationships break
down over brexit
joe biden could pay a symbolic visit to
the irish border to emphasize concerns
some tories did worry how close this
came in september
the overarching principle of britain
abiding
and supporting and defending
international law
you know should not be questioned at all
and i'm sorry i think we should
apologize to the americans that we even
opened up this pandora's box i
i think in hindsight when we read the
memoirs
it was an area of judgment it will be
less of a problem if donald trump stays
president
change brings challenges here now
south of the thames is the new us
embassy
architecture symbolizing i suspect for
many their current relationship with the
united states
it's imposing it's impregnable and it's
not all together inviting
now will that change after next tuesday
veterans in the uk of a change of white
house say
not the intelligence relationship
amongst other things makes sure
of that but because we need them more
than they need us
it does prompt a bout of introspection
every four years
one downing street veteran said optics
of a new relationship were often
obsessed over too much the nuts and
bolts of the us uk relationship
carry on really regardless of whoever is
in the white house and whoever is
in number 10 but these moments of
transition are always very nervous
for the number 10 team they will be
looking to get an early phone call
with a new president they'll be looking
to get an early visit
if he wins joe biden will want to show
he is a good
global citizen will boris johnson help
him do that
can boris johnson help him do that sam
coates sky news